sentite questa musica
stiamo rendendo conto che si è beccato
e un altro spazio
e un altro tempo
e non è più del dato ai minuti dalle ore
dai secondi che portano tanelli un
elogio sul polso o se parlava dei
sentimenti
delle emozioni
e quello che state sentendo e questo
istante questo secondo
e ci facciamo adesso a capire che stiamo
entrando in un altra dimensione
cominciamo a sentire anzi che le dei
[Musica]
vedete
io sono
l'insegnante di yoga una cantante
che cos'è il suo respiro con il tempo ma
guardato a capire che ho bisogno della
mia di tutta la mia casa tragica
per sostenermi sul palco
avviare sempre di più il respiro
noi nascerà un respiro e moriamo con un
respiro sapevate
siete mai accorti
vi siete mai accorti che il respiro non
ci abbandona mai
e sempre con noi in ogni istante
qualsiasi cosa che facciamo ogni momento
anche quando abbiamo irrigidiamo gli
occhi di respiro che dicono è che come
una macchina continua a fare quello che
noi non sappiamo neanche stare facendo
ieri sono arrivato a liegi in questa
città meravigliosa piena di altri
ed è successo la coincidenza è secondo
me le coincidenze non esistono sono sei
da portare a casa
appena sono sceso dall'autobus ho
trovato una farfalla per terra non
volava più era in grado di volare l'ho
presa e l'ho portata con me
perché è ridicolo è stato un serio è
stato segna perché lei ho capito che
stavo vedendo quello che è di 3g hanno
visto gli antichi greci non usato una
parola su che
anima
respiri e la stessa cosa era un oggetto
che entrava nelle e mail e psi dell'ex e
che cosa è strana e trova l'anima
piacerebbe attrice maps che partire
anche farfalla e da qui questa
coincidenza strana che non è una
coincidenza
perché la farfalla perché è una farfalla
ci dava il senso di quanta bellezza cioè
delle permanenze in una cosa che passa e
non tornerà di quanto indica unico quel
momento da affermare
per me è stato molto emozionante
ovvero libro ho deciso di cambiare il
mio speciali l'ultimo perché era un
serio ed è bello cogliere questi segni
allora usiamo questo segno in questo
momento noi qui per fare un percorso di
far cammino lo stesso cabina dove mi
trovo io in questo momento
cammino di consapevolezza che si
chiamava sommesse che si chiama 7
guardano come lo chiamò ricredersi un
cammino di piena consapevolezza
incominciamo ad essere in questo modo
pensiamo all'aria come all'acqua
h2o le molecole di idrogeno materassi c
quando piove certo cococcia
l'acqua
confluisce in un fiume in una grondaia
bonamico lo stesso che porta quanto sia
grande l'acqua si ritrova sempre
esporre
come c'è scritto della massima di verte
chiodi that she di apollo della
conoscenza quanto rei tutto scorre
esporre e quando scorre oltre il suo
passaggio al q3 allora perché accusato
ho usato l'acqua perché l'acqua lo
vediamo è tangibile lariano
la gattona noi ma non la vediamo eppure
entra e tra dentro di noi e va a coprire
tutto il nostro corpo dai capillari alle
cellule alle nostre arterie alle nostre
ossa e la nostra mente
e da non entra dalle narici abbiamo
anche la bocca lo siamo più per mangiare
ma il naso il primo contatto che abbiamo
tra l'esterno e l'interno come se
fossero due punti lontani tutti diversi
ma conte non certo il nostro mondo
interiore
veramente
eppure lo si crede
i proprietari della terra se crede il
protagonista di questo grande racconto
chiamato mondo
perché
eppure c'è qualcosa che respira meglio
di lui che respira molto più di noi lo
chiamiamo il polmone del mondo
stiamo parlando del mondo delle piante e
il mondo degli alberi
sebbene calloni williams nel suo libro
quale savi parla della cecità delle
piante l'uomo e cerco davanti alle
piante non le vede
fateci caso quando uscirete entro oggi
fateci caso quante volte incontrate le
piante quando le vedete che cosa succede
se fate caso le osservate io sì adesso
li osservo ci parlo e guardo le sorrido
perché anche loro respira e se il
respiro che ce n'è più male c'è niente
vivi
qui oggi voglio credere che anche
portavoce di
appello che ha fatto il professore
stefano manca usa ha chiesto una cosa
che sembra così facile mario da è
veramente difficile
piantiamo alberi
piatti a
piazzare altri significati a dare nuova
aria avere una capacità per respirare di
più respirare meglio e dobbiamo sentirci
una grande comunità come una foresta noi
siamo tutti parte della collettività
perché hanno ripetuto così tante volte
perché a ripetere le parole usare le
parole giuste crea una realtà
le parole che scegliamo quante volte le
ripetiamo creano la nostra realtà come
se fosse un mantra
4 che mi ripeto tutti i giorni e io che
sono create del mio padre e mia madre
italiano si chiama io posso
fare è passare
ai
passanti
[Musica]
sì perché lo zio topolino
si
[Risate]
[Musica]
possa dichiarare per lo ripeto
cominciamo a pensare di migliorare e lo
facciamo adesso qui il nostro piccolo a
migliorare qualcosa di noi che se però
qui o semplice chi a casa vita questo
video si potrà sapere
che cosa faccio qui
beh ve lo dico facciamo assolutamente
niente
il cammino della consapevolezza parte da
non avere nessuna pretesa
da non sentire per forza nulla
semplicemente osserviamo comincerete a
non dare qualcosa della vostra postura
magari le spalle ricominciato a cadere e
non credo spazio alla nostra capacità
polmonare e magari comincio dalla mano e
portare la mia schiava assolato
aggiustate le nostre sedute media
qualche spostamento
è infatti cominciato aggiustare porto
alle spalle verso il basso
lascio che però è stato il mio corpo
ritrovi la sua barbania come si chiama
questa canzone che ha composto marchese
era composta per farci fare questo piace
è cambiato il nostro pil
il vostro viso
sicuramente sarà certo
ci saranno delle tensioni a livello
particolare cominciato a far catella e
alla nostra città sul quadrante a
lasciarla morbida possiamo anche
chiudere gli occhi per fare questo
viaggio è totale rilassamento
e poi cominciamo anche per gli occhi e
cominciato a respirare solo ne penso
cominciamo a fare esercizi di
respirazione che si chiama ravaglia ma
è un osservazione
osserviamo il percorso che crea il
respiro dalle 10
a lavoro fino ai polmoni
ecco
come ed ormoni
[Musica]
ora vi lascio a questo
mi raccomando voi continuate a uscire